name any specific names but there's
people in his organization who are
basically very large fans of mine and
are a part of GCC so I know the inner
workings of his business his retention
his customer demographic everything
obviously that's his business it's none
of my right to spill any of that stuff I
don't think you could ever call hustle's
University it's like calling my software
company okay if it's such a cam after
first month refund and cancel your
subscription you know like it's very
impressive he's been able to keep people
there that long and I will say there's
some psychological stuff that they do
the child there is some psychological
stuff that they do that is very cultish
I will say to keep people that long but
is it a net negative or not positive I
would say it's in general a net positive
I won't yeah I wouldn't say Andrew
Tate's a scam artist for having his
Hustler's University this guy so far two
videos has a lot of diplomacy which I
think is a really high level quality I
mean it's just the way he's talking you
know I he he's very articulate he's
articulate but I mean he's he he's
saying I've seen behind the curtain at
Tates but I'm not gonna give away his
Secrets because I'm not that kind of guy
he's saying you know in a very
diplomatic way yeah is there it's a net
positive but you know he he is sort of
acknowledging that there may be in a
low-key way that there may be some
[ __ ] behind the curtain but well I
could tell you what it's what it is
mostly positive when people sign up for
for Hustler's University his like
monthly subscription they say if you're
like if you miss a payment or you cancel
they're like they don't let you back in
he's like yeah he tastes there with this
like shirt off getting massage he's like
yeah I've had guys email me to let me
back in and I'm like no you can't get
back in but it's just realistically a
psychological thing to get people to
make sure they're paying and that they
want to stay well I can see that but
which is it's pretty dumb you can't even
have a jail for a jail for hustle
University you just make a different
email I mean
if somebody hasn't made their money yet
and they're freaking card got declined
and you know months later they're like
dude I got my [ __ ] together you know
like I said it's not that deep you just
use a different card like I don't even
know why that's people get so the hu
jail good option you know you're not
you're living in a different world dude
I guess that's probably one of the
biggest mistakes that people make look
if you're hanging out with girls don't
ever tag them okay
just look don't ever tag him don't ever
put them on your stories number one way
you know that a girl is an actual friend
of mine is if I tag them if I tag them
or for example on any of my store like
Photo dumps on Instagram if they're
tagged that means we've never had sex or
we've had sex and then they've been
sisters never tag girls totally smart
very smart why do you think it's smart
I'm actually curious about that is it
like a psychological thing when somebody
else thinks something I I've never
tagged a girl in my story on a regular
dude it makes a girl feel like she's got
a little a little bit of a special nod
and it makes her think that she's a
little bit more that he's a little
little bit more serious about her
definitely I will never be legally
married especially in a place like that
okay the rights are very very heavily
skewed towards women look I'll be
outside I have a great greatest game for
the government like I absolutely despise
the government
um I think they are the biggest criminal
organization on Earth uh I'm absolutely
disgusted uh with paying taxes I've paid
a lot of taxes from day one I've done a
lot of things to you know legally avoid
as much tax not of Aid so I definitely
don't want the government involved don't
blame them he makes a lot of money why
do you want your girls being able to
screw you over like that that's just one
less liability not getting married I
believe in a prenups I do if a man was
yeah but then when you bust out the
prenup that's when they start bitching
and they don't want to do it they're
like why do you think we need the prenup
you don't love me I think we might not
work out well I think a really
intelligent high value woman would say
you know what this guy's got bazillions
of dollars and I understand why he has
to do that yeah and fantasy land that
happens I would want to pre-dem I
wouldn't even care I wouldn't be
insulted by it but yes 20 years ago
might I have been like oh my God he
doesn't really love me yes I might have
well you're right but I understand it
your mom said it's different I think you
can commit to somebody I also he needs
to be careful of of the United States
because all the liberal states have
common law marriage where even if you
don't get marriage married but you live
with someone long enough you're
considered you're considered you're
considered a partner and you have I
didn't even know that you have certain
rights that a spouse would have yeah so
property and money and it's it's crazy
so you got to be real careful make sure
that girls got a different address you
got me Ben you know my best advice in
terms of you know not getting attached
is here's the thing like this whole like
soulmate thing is such [ __ ] you
probably have infinite amounts of soul
mates what it is it's there's people who
there's a predisposition like you guys
have the same values morals beliefs yo
predisposition for attraction then it's
also a matter of timing for me in terms
of knocking attached it's simply just
knowing that hey you know what maybe
this one fell through your cracks maybe
this one doesn't like you there's a
thousand and one other people out there
that you'll have that same sort of
connection with and you will have that
same sort of connection it's just a
matter of finding them and also finding
them at the right time yeah no I don't
believe in soulmates either I think
that's just a big thing to get people
trapped into relationships
you believe in soul mates yeah I found
my soul mate like you're stuck with them
it's [ __ ] it's [ __ ] Rose don't
realize that's a a girl will never date
I don't care what she's a girl won't
date a guy who makes less money than her
a girl it's not a truth right and of
course there are some rare instances or
this hour if you're a Dell right like I
get it but for the most part I'd say
it's different for people my age right
now because if you're working like if
I'm making 18 an hour and the girls
making like 22 an hour it's not it's not
like as big of a deal yeah but if you're
older and looking for a more serious
relationship
um girls typically don't want to be the
Breadwinners of the relationship I feel
like that's just natural thing for guys
to be the leaders make the money and
provide I just think it's attractive for
personally I think
if thing I don't know if it's about
dollars and cents as much
in the short term but I think a woman
does look at what is this guy's
long-term possibility yes 99.9 case the
girls won't date a guy who makes less
money than the thing is if you're a girl
who makes a hundred thousand a month
your dating pool just got a hell of a
lot smaller right that's true so yeah
Australia yeah I mean that's a really
unique scenario so obviously but he's
saying that's the point one percent of
girls girls like being with winners like
no [ __ ] what would you say to a young
man watching this 16 to get your bread
up go to the gym and you'll get girls
no like you want people
not a bunch well you're able to find a
higher quality girl if you have your
[ __ ] together and then if you're Josh
Moe run around the block Maybe
no let's
fight but I was 14 I started my business
and then when I was 16 I in was getting
three four hours of sleep two hours of
sleep falling asleep when I went to
school building my business for me and
Mama by the time I was 17. like you
that's Butch par borderline creepy
when I went to school
that does look like it does like similar
hairline black t-shirts
this this and Greg Heffley
they had a baby
yeah out pops little Sunny fast
oh [ __ ] though look at that it's funny
we started building my business for me
and Mama by the time I was 17 I had
employees dropped out of school and
basically 2017 2018 2019 all I did up
until December 2019. all I did was work
to the point where like I even had like
best friends be like dude I haven't seen
you in four months and you live five
minutes away from me I'm like yeah I'm
building so dramatic but yeah I get the
point I mean I still love to hang out
with my friends and I don't take that
for granted I mean yeah I don't take it
for granted like I really enjoy and
appreciate the time I hang out with
friends but I work all day you do take
time I like that you take time to spend
with the people you left and I do work
all day you spend time with family you
spend time with friends but you also
work your ass off when you're not doing
that and I think that's great and I
couldn't even function off of two four
hours of sleep like I get the big
entrepreneurs that say that [ __ ] but
[ __ ] that oh my God you and me near our
sleep huh no yeah we sleep like sleepy
people princes do you play any console
do I look like I'm 12 to you ladies and
gentlemen I think the last time I ever
played a video game out of my own accord
was when I was 13 years old I really
just don't understand why anyone on
Earth would want to commit so much time
to a fake World a fake video game when
we're living in the coolest video game
in existence I just don't get it and
this is also why the metaverse so much
because I know it's just going to be
another extension of like this weird
world
why would you want to make your life so
good in some fake world when we've got
the real world like we're playing a
video because some people are
hospital-bound and they're paralyzed and
they have nothing and they can't 99 of
people aren't playing video games aren't
hospitalized and paralyzed that is a
ridiculous analogy there are a lot of
sick people come out of come out of
fantasy level even when I was playing
fortnite all day I was trying to be a
professional and trying to be a like a
big streamer but if I was just playing
all day not trying to do any of that
then I I wouldn't have even I don't know
you were yeah like I was at least trying
to have a goal and even if it's
something cringy like trying to become a
professional fortnite player I was at
least I was at least going after like a
big goal shut up
don't talk to the animals like that
hey I'll kill him all right
he's kidding but yeah um it's only fast
dog abuser
um no yeah but acting like Tommy he
streams all day and makes a lot of money
so he's not like just doing nothing like
he is building a brand and business for
himself you know what I mean 99.9999 of
people who watch my stuff you will never
ever reach my level at this age because
what I've accomplished in my life I
don't believe is necessarily
aspirational because I do believe you
have to have a certain degree of a
mental illness to push this far the
people who are like the most wealthy and
successful I can tell you right now they
don't have peace in their life so with
that being said to get for example to my
position where you've made whatever I
lost track but let's say 25 ish to get
to that point in life I said there's so
much chaos that needs to happen like
you're not going to be able to stop and
appreciate it it really is is true
though because I know when I was like
running a company and we'd have like a
big a big drop coming up where a lot of
money would be coming in you'd be like
oh my God like I feel like I'm doing
non-stop work up until this point and
then from there you're able to click
chill but then after that it's always
just like oh well you know I'm chilled
I've chilled for like an hour like what
what's next what's next you have to work
your ass off everybody thinks that this
is you know we're sitting here filming
for an hour and we work an hour a day
there's a lot more behind the scenes on
anything you see
um you know you'll see somebody with a
quote unquote overnight success and you
know they've been working for years
behind the scenes on building whatever
you know their particular craft is so
yeah you do have to really want
something
and want it to the point where you know
nothing you obsess over it you're
obsessed over it you have to love that's
why loving what you're doing I think is
crucial you want you want a YouTube
channel how many YouTube videos have you
posted how many tick tocks have you
posted promoting your YouTube channel
yeah like what do you really want if you
want it that bad just go and do it have
you planned your content calendar what
you're going to put out every day have
you even have you even wrote down a plan
or your goals or are you just saying
this to your friends when you're getting
high like what what are you doing right
a question for you
didn't make you happy no it hasn't made
me happy whatsoever in fact I think it
comes with its own set of challenges I
think the happiest stage is between 10
and 30k 10 10 to 30k a month right right
because then you can kind of travel and
you can kind of do like 99 of things you
would really want to do in life I find
once you get past that amount you get
used to stuff like I mean there's no
amount of shopping I could ever do for
myself that would give me any
um any Joy No I watched two bites that's
why it's not about like trying it's what
is it called a vice when you're looking
up to something no what what is it we
was in church like an idol if you idle
stuff like cars and stupid [ __ ] that you
can spend money on you'll never get
hacked but if you if you look at having
like freedom and being able to give to
family and help others out that's what
will truly make you happy for making
money I get so much hate in my comments
about promoting making money and these
people don't even understand the real
point of making money they don't even
think it's important they're fine with
sitting around all day doing [ __ ]
you know what I mean it's it's like
worrying about their bills worrying
about their bills not being able to
travel having to go to that job that
[ __ ] low paid job for 40 hours a week
asking the government for handouts if
you have money you can hang out with
your friends in cooler places and do it
more you know like you don't just have
to buy cool cars and [ __ ] that's not
what it's about yeah
what would I do I would sit around on
the kitchen table because buy dogs yeah
I buy land and dogs and I would help on
my family there's a long list of things
I would do but socially I would sit at
my kitchen table with my friends which
I've done poor wealthy regardless
because it's my favorite thing to do but
it would be a cooler table and it would
be bigger for more friends and there
would be plenty like the food we love
the most and all those things and and i
i people that say oh the rich people
rich or bad they're painting this whole
population of people with a wide brush
that is just stupid to do to any
population yeah and guess what making
money also makes it easier to actually
achieve your goals like right now I have
money so it's so much easier for me to
get into content creation hire a whole
team of editors hire assistants it makes
things that you actually want to do
easier you know there's a whole set of
benefits to money that people don't even
realize you tried to hire the dog walker
and I said no you're doing it
no
[Music]
[Music]